the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
quick quick recap of what we did last
time so last time we introduced this
idea of decomposition and abstraction
and we started putting that into our
programs these were sort of high-level
concepts and we achieved them using
these concrete things called functions
in our programs and functions allowed us
to create code that was coherent
that was that had some structure to it
and was reusable okay and from now on in
problem sets and in lectures I'm going
to be using functions a lot so make sure
that you understand how they work and
all of those details so today we're
going to introduce two new data types
and they're called compound data types
because they're actually data types that
are made up of other data types
particularly ants floats boolean z' and
strings and actually not just these but
other data types as well so that's why
they're called compound data types so
we're going to look at a new data type
called a tuple and then you did a data
type called a list and then we're going
to talk about these ideas that come
about with specifically with lists all
right so let's go right into tuples okay
so if your recall strings strings were
sequences of characters okay tuples are
going to be similar to strings in that
they're going to be sequences of
something so if that tuples aren't just
sequences of characters they can be
sequences of of anything they're a
collection of data where that data can
be of any type so the so a tuple can
contain elements that are integers
floats strings and so on tuples are
immutable and if you recall we talked
about this word a little bit when we
talked about strings so that means once
you create a tuple object you can't
modify it just like when you created a
string object you weren't able you were
not allowed to modify it so the way we
create tuples are with these open and
close parentheses this shouldn't be
confused with a function because there's
nothing there's no there's no
this isn't a function call it's just how
you represent a tuple for a function
call you'd have something right before
the parentheses okay this is just how we
chose to represent a tuple and just a
plain open and close parentheses
represents an empty tuple so it's of
length 0 there's nothing in it
oops you can create a tuple that
contains some elements by separating
each element with a comma so in this
case this is a tuple that can be
accessed with a variable T that contains
three elements the first is an integer
the second this is a string and the
third is another integer much like
strings we can index into tuples to find
out values at particular indices so you
read this as T at position 0 so the
tuple represented by variable T at
position 0 will evaluate to 2 because
again we start counting from 0 in
computer science so that brings us gives
us the first element just like strings
we can concatenate tuples together that
just means add them together so if we
add these two tuples together we just
get back one larger tuple that's just
those two the elements of those tuples
just put together in one larger tuple
again much like strings we can slice
into tuples so T slice from index 1
until index 2 remember we go until this
stop minus 1 so this only gives us one
element inside the tuple and this is not
a mistake
this extra comma here actually
represents a tuple object okay if I
didn't have this comma here then this
would just be a string the parenthesis
would just wouldn't really make any
difference but the comma here makes it
clear to Python that this is a tuple
with only one element in it we can slice
even further to get a tuple with two
elements and we can do the usual
operations like get the length of a
tuple which says how many elements are
in my tuple
Len of this tea would evaluate to 3
because there are three elements inside
the tuple each element again separated
by the comma and just like strings if we
try to change a value inside the tuple
in this case I wanted to try to change
the value of the second the second
element to four Python doesn't allow
that because tuples are immutable okay
so why would we want to use two poles
tuples are actually useful in a couple
of different scenarios
so recall couple few lectures ago we
looked at this code where we try to swap
the values of variables x and y and this
first code actually didn't work because
you're overriding the value for x right
so instead what we ended up doing was
creating this temporary variable where
we stored the value of x and then we
overrode it and then we use the
temporary variable what turns out this
three liner code right here can actually
be written in one line using tuples so
you say X comma Y is equal to Y comma X
and Python goes in and says what's the
value of y and assigns it to X and then
what's the value of X and assigns it to
Y
extending on that we can actually use
tuples to return more than one value
from a function so functions you're only
allowed to return one object okay so
you're not allowed to return more than
one object however if we use an op a
tuple object and if that's the thing
that we return we can actually get
around this sort of rule by putting in
as many values as we want inside the
tuple object and then we can return as
many values as we'd like so in this
specific example I'm trying to calculate
the quotient and remainder when we
divide X by Y so this is a function
definition here and down here I'm
calling the function with four and five
so when I make the function call whoops
four gets assigned to X and five gets
assigned to Y right so then Q is going
to be the integer division when X's is
divided by Y and this double slash just
means it's like casting the result to an
integer it says divide it keep the whole
number part and just delete everything
else beyond the decimal point so when
you divide four by five this Q is
actually going to be zero that's zero
point something and I don't care about
the point something and then the
remainder is just using the percent
operator so when I divide four by five
there the remainder is going to be four
and notice that I'm going to be
returning Q and R which are these two
values that I calculated inside my
function and I'm returning them in the
context of this tuple right so I'm only
returning one object which is a tuple it
just so happens that I'm populating that
object with a few few different values
okay so when I return when the function
returns here this is going to say 0
comma 4
that's the tuple it's going to return
right q is going to be 0 and R is going
to be 4 so then this line here quote REM
equals 0 4 is basically this little it's
sort of like what we did up here
so it assigns quote to four quotes I
quote to zero and REM to four okay so we
can use tuples this is very useful we
can use them to return more than one
value from a function so tuples are
great might seem a little bit confusing
at first but they're actually pretty
useful because they hold collections of
data so here I wrote a function which I
can apply to any set of data okay and
I'll explain what this function does and
then we can apply it to some data and
you can see that you can extract some
very basic information from whatever set
of data that you happen to collect so
here's a function called get data and it
does all of this stuff in here
and in the actual code associated with
the lecture I actually said what the
condition on a tuple was so it has to be
a tuple of a certain that looks a
certain way and this is the way that has
to look so it's one tuple the outer
square the outer parentheses out here
represent the fact that it's a tuple and
the elements of this tuple are actually
other tuples right so the first element
is a tuple object the second element
tuple object and third one's a tuple
object and so on and each one of these
inner two pull objects are actually
going to contain two elements the first
being an integer in the second being a
string so that's sort of the
precondition that this function assumes
on a tuple before it can before it
actually it can work alright so given a
tuple that looks like that what's the
function going to do its first creating
two empty tuples one is called nums and
what is called words and then there's a
for loop and notice here the for loop is
going to iterate over every element
inside the tuple remember in strings
when we were able to use for loops that
iterated over the characters directly as
opposed over the indices where we're
doing this same sort of thing here
instead of iterating over the indices
we're going to iterate over the tuple
object at each
decision okay so first time through the
loop T here is going to be this first
tuple the second time through the loop T
is going to be this tuple and the third
time it's going to be this exact tuple
object okay so each time through the
loop what I'm doing is I'm going to have
this nums tuple that I'm going to keep
adding to and each time I'm going to
create a new object and reassign it to
this variable nums
and each time through the loop I'm
looking at what the previous value of
nums was so what was my previous tuple
and I'm going to add it with this
singleton tuple so it's a tuple of one
character or one element this element
being T at position zero so you have to
sort of wrap your mind wrapp wrap your
mind around how this is working so if T
is going to be this tuple element right
here then T at position zero is going to
be this blue bar here so it represents
the integer portion of the tuple okay so
as we're going through the loop this
nums is going to get populated with all
of the integers from every one of my
tuple in side tuple objects so that's
basically what this line here is doing
at the same time I'm also populating
this words tuple Nords tuple is a little
bit different because I'm not adding
every single one of these string objects
so T at position one being the string
part of the inner tuple I'm actually
adding the string part only if it's not
already in my words list okay so here
I'm essentially grabbing all of the
unique strings from my list these last
sort of three lines three four lines
here just do a little bit of arithmetic
on it saying okay now I have my all of
the numbers here what's the minimum out
of all of these and then what's the
maximum out of all of these and then
this unique words variable tells me how
many unique words do I have in my
original tuple
so this feels sort of generic so let's
let's let's run it on some data so here
I have it I tested it on some test data
and then I got some actual data okay and
this actual data that I wanted to
analyze was Taylor Swift data and
representing the integer portion of the
tuple representing a year and the string
portion of the tuple representing the
the person who she wrote a song about
that year okay so some real world data
that we're working with here very
important that we know this this
information okay so with this data I can
run it I can plug it into my this
function that I wrote up here and I'm
going to actually comment this out so it
doesn't get cluttered and if I run it
this is the part where I'm calling my
function I'm calling it with this data
here t-swift being this tuple of tuples
and what I get back is up here line 38
is the return from the function being a
large tuple and that large tuple I'm
then assigning it to my own tuple in my
program and then I'm just writing out
printing out some statement here okay so
I'm getting the minimum year the maximum
year and then the number of people so I
can show you that it works if I replace
one of these names with another one that
I already have in here so instead of
writing a song about five people she
would have wrote a song about four
people yeah it worked
okay so so that's two poles and remember
or recall keep in mind two poles were
immutable now we're going to look at a
very very similar data structure to
tuples called lists so that instead of
lists being immutable lists are going to
be mutable object objects okay so much
like lists they're going to contain
elements of any type or objects of any
type you denote them with you to note a
list with square brackets instead of
parentheses and the difference being
that they're going to be mutable objects
instead of immutable so creating an
empty list you just do open close square
brackets you can have a list of elements
of different types even oops even a list
of of Lists so one of the elements being
a list as usual you can apply lengths on
a list and that tells you how many
elements are in it this is going to tell
you how many elements are in your list l
so it's not going to look any further
than that right so it's going to say
this is an integer this is a string this
is an integer this is a list it's not
going to say how many elements are in
this list okay it's just going to look
at the outer sort of the shell of the
shell of elements indexing and slicing
works the same way so L opposition zero
gives you the value two you can index
into a list and then do something with
the value that you get back so L at
position two says that's this value
there and add one to it L a position
three that's going to be this list here
notice it evaluates to another list
you're not allowed to index outside of
the length of the list so that's going
to give you an error because we only
have four elements and you can also have
expressions for your index so this
Python just replaces I with two here and
say what's and says what's L at position
one and it grabs that from in there
okay so very very similar to the kinds
of operations we've seen on strings and
and tuples maybe one difference and
that's what we're going to focus on for
the rest of this class is that lists are
mutable mutable objects okay so what
does that mean internally internally
that means let's say we have a list L
and we assign it sorry let's say we have
a variable L that's going to point to a
list with three elements - one and three
okay they're all the HH elements is an
integer when we were dealing with with
tuples or with strings if we reassigned
if we try to do this line right here we
had an error but this is actually
allowed with lists so when you execute
that line Python is going to look at
that middle element and it's going to
change its value from a 1 to a 5 and
that's just due to the mutability nature
of the list okay so now notice that this
list variable this variable L which
originally pointed to this list points
to the exact same list we haven't
created a new object in memory we're
just modifying the same object in memory
and you're going to see why this is
important as we look at a few side
effects that can happen when when you
have this so I've said this a couple
times before but it's um it'll make your
life a lot easier if you try to think of
when you when you want to iterate
through a list if you try to think about
iterating through the eat through the
elements directly it's a lot more
pythonic I've used that word before so
this is sort of a common pattern that
you're going to see where you're
iterating over the list elements
directly right we've done it over two
pools we've done it over strings so
these are identical codes they do the
exact same thing except on the left
you're going from you're going through 0
1 2 3 and so on and then you're indexing
into each one of these each one of these
numbers to get the element value whereas
on the right this this loop variable I
is going to have the element value
itself okay so this code on the right is
a lot cleaner okay so now let's look at
some operations that we can do on lists
okay so there's a lot more operations
that we can do on lists because of their
mutability aspect then we can do on
tuples or strings for example okay so
here's a few of them and they're going
to take advantage of this mutability
concept so we can add elements directly
to the end of the list using this
funky-looking notation l dot append and
then the element we we want to add to
the end okay and this operation mutates
the list so if I have L is equal to 2 1
3 and I append the element 5 to the end
then L the same L is going to point to
the same object except is going to have
an extra number at the end 5 okay but
now what's this dot right we haven't
really seen this before okay and it's
going to become apparent what it means
in a few lectures from now but for the
moment you can think of as of this dot
as an operation it's it's like applying
a function except that the function that
you're applying can only work on certain
types of objects okay so in this case
append for example is the function we're
trying to apply and we want to apply it
to whatever is before the dot which is
the object ok and appends only been
defined to work with a list object for
example which is why we're using the dot
in this case we wouldn't be able to use
append on an integer for example because
it that sort of functions not defined on
an integer so for now you'll sort of
have to remember or remember which which
are functions that work with a dot and
which are functions like Len that aren't
with a dot
but in a couple lectures I promise it
will be a lot clearer okay so for now
just think of it as whatever is before
the dot is the object you're applying a
function to and whatever's after the dot
is the function you're applying on the
object okay so we can add things to the
end of our list we can also combine
lists together using the plus operator
okay
the plus operator does not mutate the
list okay instead it gives you a new
list that's the sum of those two lists
combined so in this case if L 1 is 2 1 3
and L 2 is 4 5 6 when we add those two
lists together that's going to give us
an entirely new list leaving L 1 and L 2
the same and that's why we have to we
have to assign the result of the
addition to a new list otherwise the
results lost if you want to mutate a
list directly and make it longer by the
elements within another list then you
can use this extend function or extent
method okay and this is going to mutate
L 1 directly so if L 1 was 2 1 3 if you
extend it by the list 0 6 it's just
going to tack on 0 6 to L 1 directly so
notice l1 has been mutated okay
okay so that's adding things to list we
can also delete things from lists right
we don't just want to keep adding to our
lists because then they become very very
big so let's see how we can delete some
some items from our list there's a few
ways first one being you can use this
del function and this says delete from
the list l the element at this index
okay so you give it the index 0 1 2 or
whatever you want whatever index you
want to delete the element at if you
just want to delete the element at the
end of the list that's the farthest
right you do l dot pop if you want to
remove a specific element so you know
there's somewhere in your list there's
you know there's the number 5 and you
want to delete it from the list then you
say l dot remove and you say what
element you want to remove and that only
removes the very first occurrence of it
so if there's two fives in your list
then it's only going to remove the very
first one okay so let's take a look at
this sort of sequence of sequence of
commands so we have first L is equal to
this this long list here and I want to
mention that all of these operations are
going to mutate our list which is why I
wrote this comment here that says assume
that you're doing these in order ok so
as you're doing these in order you're
going to be mutating your list and if
you're mutating your list you have to
remember that you're working with this
new mutated list ok so the first thing
we're doing is we're removing two from
our list so when you remove - this says
look for an element with the value 2 and
take it away from the list so that's the
very first one here so the list we're
left with is just everything after it
then I want to remove 3 from the list
and notice there's two of them there's
this 3 here and there's this 3 here so
we're going to remove only the first one
okay which is this one here so the list
we're left with is 1 6 3 7 0 then we're
going to delete from the list l the
element at position 1 so starting
counting from 0 the element at position
1 is this one
here so we've removed that and we're
left with one three seven zero and then
when we do l dot pop that's going to
delete the element furthest to the right
so at the end of the list which is that
zero so then we're left with only one
three and seven okay and l dot pop is
often useful because it tells you the
return value from l dot pop is going to
be the value that it removed so in this
case it's going to return zero I want to
mention though that some of the so these
functions all mutate the list you have
to be careful with return values so
these are all you can all you can think
of all of these as functions right that
operate on a list except that what these
functions do is they take in the list
and they modify it okay but as functions
they obviously return something back to
whoever called them right and oftentimes
they're going to return the value none
okay so for example if you are going to
do l dot remove two and you print that
out that might print out none for you
okay so you can't just assign the value
of this to a variable and expect it to
be the mutated list right the list that
the list got mutated
the list that got mutated is the list
that was passed into here okay we're
gonna look at one example in a few
slides that's going to show this okay
another thing that we can do and this is
often useful when you're working with
data is to convert lists of strings and
then strings to lists okay sometimes a
might be useful to work with with
strings as opposed to a list and vice
versa
okay so this first line here lists s
takes in a string and casts it to a list
so much like we cast a float to an
integer for example you're just casting
a string to a list here and when you do
that at this line so if this is your s
here when you do list s this is going to
give you a list looks like this where
every single character in s is going to
be its own element so that means
everywhere character is going to be a
string and it's going to be separated by
a comma so including spaces
okay sometimes you don't want each
character in the list to be its own
element sometimes you want for example
if you're given a sentence you might
want to have everything in between
spaces being its own element
so that will give you every word in the
sentence for example in that case you're
going to use split in this case I've
split over the less than sign but again
if you're doing the the sentence example
you might want to split on a space so
this is going to take everything in
between the sign that you're interested
in in this case the less than sign and
it's going to set it as a separate
element in the list so that's how you
convert string strings to lists and
sometimes you are given a list and you
might want to convert it to a string so
that's where this join method or
function is useful so this is an empty
string so it's just open close quote
right away no space so this just joins
every every one of the elements in the
list together so to return this string
ABC and then you can join on any
character that you would want so in this
case you can join on the underscore okay
so to put whatever characters in here
and between every one of the elements in
your list pretty useful functions okay a
couple other operations we can do on
lists and these are also pretty useful
is to sort lists into reverse lists and
many many others in the Python
documentation so sort and sorted both
sort lists but one of them mutates the
list and the other one does not and
sometimes it's useful to use one and
sometimes it's useful to use the other
okay so if I have this list L is equal
to nine 6:03 sorted you can think of it
as give me the sorted version of L gives
you back the sorted version of L so it
returns a new list that's the sorted
version of the input list and does not
mutate
so keeps out the exact same way so this
will be replaced by the sorted version
of the list which you can assign to a
variable and then do whatever you want
with it like l2 is equal to sorted out
for example okay and it keeps all the
same on the other hand if you just want
to mutate L and you don't care about
getting another copy that's sorted you
just do L dot sort and that's going to
automatically sort L for you and L now
contain L net L is now the sorted the
sorted version of L similarly reverse is
going to take L and reverse all the
character all the elements in it so the
last one is the first one the second
last one is the second one and so on so
lists are mutable we've said that so
many times this lecture but what exactly
does that mean what implications does
that does that have okay once again this
next part of the lecture Python tutor
just type you know paste all the code in
and go step by step to see exactly
what's what's happening so lists are
mutable as you have variable variable
names so for example L is equal to some
list that L is going to be pointing to
the list in memory okay and since it's a
mutable object this list you can have
more than one variable that points to
the exact same object in memory okay and
if you have more than one variable that
points to the same object in memory if
that object in memory is changed then
when you access it through any one of
these variables they're all going to
give you the changed the changed object
value okay so the key phrase to keep in
mind when you're dealing with lists is
what side effects could happen right if
you're mutating a list if you're doing
operations on lists what what side
effects you know what variables might be
affected by by this change okay let's
come back down to earth for a sec
and okay this will wake a lot of people
up okay so let's do an analogy with with
people okay let's say we have a person a
person this case Justin Bieber is going
to be an object right I'm an object
right I'm like the number three Bieber's
an object he's like number five right
different objects were both of type
people okay let's say a person has
different attributes right let's say we
can let's say he gets two attributes to
begin with he's a singer and he's rich
okay I can refer to this person object
by many different names right his full
name his stage name all of the fangirls
call him by these names people who
dislike him call him by other names that
I didn't put up here okay but he's known
by any by all these different names
they're all aliases or nicknames that
point to this same person object right
okay so originally let's say I say
Justin Bieber's a singer and rich those
are the two attributes
I've originally assigned to him and then
let's say I want to assign a different
attribute to him and say Justin Bieber's
singer rich and a troublemaker
I'm being kind here okay okay so if I
say Justin Bieber's these three has
these three attributes so it's the same
person I'm referring to then all of his
nicknames right are going to refer to
this exact same person so all of his
nicknames are going to or aliases will
refer to the same person object right
with these changed attributes okay does
that make sense okay so that sort of
idea arises in lists so lists is like a
person object whose value whose
attributes can change for example and as
they change all of the different aliases
for this object will point to this
changed object okay so let's see a few
examples I apologize if this is a little
a little small but this I basically copy
and pasted from the Python tutor which
is just in the from the code from
today's lecture
so I have this these lines of code here
the first couple of lines really just
show what happens when you're dealing
with non mutable objects so with non
mutable objects you have two separate
objects that get their own values and
that's it end of story with lists
however to do it there's something
different that happens so I have warm is
a variable and it's going to be equal to
this list the warm is going to point to
this list here red yellow orange it
contains three elements hot is equal to
warm means I'm creating an alias for
this list and I'm in the alias is going
to be with this variable hot
so notice warm and hot point to the
exact same object so on line eight when
I append a when I append this string
pink to my object since both of these
two variables point to the exact same
object if I'm trying to access this
object through either variable they're
going through both going to put print
out the same thing okay and that's the
side effect that's a side effect of
Lists being lists being mutable okay if
you want to create an entirely new copy
of the list then you can clone it which
sounds really cool but really it's just
making a copy of the list and you clone
it using this little notation here which
is open close square brackets with a
colon and we've sort of seen the
sensation here and this tells Python
this is 0 sorry this is 0 and this is
length cool I guess what it basically
says take every element create a new
list with those exact same elements and
assign it to the variable chill so here
if I originally have cool is equal to
blue green gray right here when I clone
it on line two with with that funky
notation I'm creating a new copy of it
and then on the next line when I'm
appending another element to the to the
copy notice I'm just
altering the copy the original stayed
the same because I've cloned it so if
you don't want to have this side effect
side effect issue then you should clone
your your your variable your list okay
so let's see a slightly more complicated
example example where you're going to
see the difference between sort and
sorted in the context of this mutability
and in side-effects issue okay so once
again let's create this warm is equal to
red yellow orange so that's what warm is
going to point to this list and then
sorted warm is equal to warm dot sort so
dot sort mutates so as soon as I do that
that list warm is now the sorted version
of it and notice that I've assigned the
return of this to sorted warm and the
return is none because L dot sort or dot
dot sort mutated the list it didn't
return a sorted version of the list it
mutated the list itself okay so when I
print warm and I sorted warm I'm praying
the mutated version and then this nun
here sort it on the other hand returns
it doesn't sort of does not sort the
list that that's given to it and instead
it returns a sorted version of the list
so in this case if cool is equal to
these three colors gray green blue if I
do sorted cool it's going to return the
sorted version of that list which is
blue green gray and it's assigned to the
variable sorted cool so when I print
them it's going to show me the two
separate lists one being the original
unsorted one and one being this sorted
version
last one's a little bit more complicated
but it shows that even though you could
you have nested even though you can have
nested lists you still you're not you
you're not you don't escape this idea of
side effects so first I'm going to
create warm is equal to these two colors
yellow orange so warm is the points to
these two colors hot is equal to this
one list a list with one element bright
colors is going to be a list and the
element inside the list is a list itself
so since it's a list it's this is your
list and the element inside here which
is a list itself is actually just
pointing to whatever warm is that object
okay then I do then I append hot to my
bright colors so the next element here
is going to be another list which means
it's just pointing to this other list
here it's not creating a copy of it okay
so each one of these elements here is
actually just pointing to these two
lists here so if I modified either one
of these then bright colors would also
be modified so let's say I add pink here
to my hot list we have red and pink then
notice that bright colors the first
element points this list and the second
element points to this list which I've
just modified last thing is I'll let you
try this as an exercise in Python tutor
but the idea here being you should be
careful as you're writing a for loop
that iterates over a list that you're
modifying inside the list in this case
I'm trying to go through the list l1 and
if I find an item that's in l1 and l2 I
want to delete it from l1 so one in two
are also in l2 so I want to delete them
from l1 and be left with three four
however the code on the left here
doesn't actually do what I think it's
doing because here I'm I'm modifying a
list as I'm iterating over it and behind
the
scenes Python keeps this this keeps
track of the index and doesn't update
the index as its as you're changing the
list so it figures out the length of the
list to begin with and how many indices
it has and doesn't update it as you're
removing items from the list so the
solution to that is to make a copy of
the list first iterate over the copy
which will remain intact and modify the
list that you want to modify inside the
loop so please run both of these in the
Python tutor and you'll see that what
ends up happening is on the left you're
going to skip over one element okay so
you show your code so that's that's
going to be the wrong code all right
you